Or teases past his prime
[inaudible] down there. Louis. Yes.
These prime. He's a good fighter.
But you know, give him, give him,
give him like 10 years. Yeah. And he
would've, he would've beat these guys.
He would have given them a good, good
fight. But right now he's, you know,
he's obviously older and um,
he's an old fighter. Yeah.
Well they caught him doing some steroids.
A lot of times guys get older,
they try to, yeah. You need it chews
up the old body. Yeah. So, you know,
when you reached that point where you
need steroids mentally, it affects you.
You know, you go into the ring and it's
like, you know, you're missing something.
Something that was there in the past
and it made you feel good. Now. Um,
I don't feel as good. When
you were fighting, did
anybody that you were finding,
did you suspect that they
were on something? Um, yeah.
Oh, a couple times. Yeah.
But the good thing is that I know is I
realized theorized steroids can never get
this strong. Your Chin. Chin. Yeah. So you
can take as much through as, as you want.
But I'm going to hitting you on the chin.
You can't put muscles in your face.
Yeah. Yeah. And then you know
these body punches, you can't,
you can't protect around here, so they'll
affect you as well. So that's where you,
you know when you hit,
when you hit the guys around here,
body punches and you hit him on the chin.
Doesn't matter.
But don't you think that it does,
it makes them stronger physically,
gives them more vitality.
It might make them able to absorb more
punishment for a minute. For minute.
Just for a little bit.
Yeah, for a little bit.
Who did you suspect was on
something when you follow them? Um,
I don't want to say you
don't want, yeah, go ahead.
Go ahead Nick Vander I plow.
Vander was the first guy
as far as I'm concerned,
was the first guy on
steroids back in the day.
They look at the fucking
size of that guy in the,
in the late nineties especially
when he filed the clinics.
Have you ever asked him if
he's been on steroids now?
I've never actually
hung out with a vendor.
I might've make your victory party 20
years ago to hanging around with the PE
guys that were like into it. I didn't
know mark, whatever his name was, his,
he was the first guy to have like a
strength and conditioning coach and,
and all that kind of stuff's Dietitian.
Spanx did when he fought. Um,
when you fought Larry Holmes, he guy,
same guy. Mackey shall stone. Yeah.
Mackey shells.
Stone got him in shape for Larry when
he was coming up from light heavyweight.
Yeah. That's the same guy that
Vander used and they're doing,
it was really interesting because at the
time the conventional wisdom was that
box or should not lift weights
and the Vander was lifted,
all kinds of weights and
he put on all this muscle,
but really he was only about 200,
205 pounds when he first fought fog.
Heavy traps. Oh yeah. Jesus Christ.
He was built, it was built. It was PR.
Perfect body. Yeah. That's not steroids.
Steroids,
but necessarily you definitely
can get that big without it.
I mean there are guys, the words
allegedly, yeah. Alleged a good word,
but it's also possible to
get that big with steroids.
But it's not just steroids too. It's
EPO. There's a look at that one up there.
Yeah. But this is in the
night, eighties and nineties.
The good stuff wasn't available
back then, was it? Oh yeah.
What are you kidding me man?
Those Russians had everything
back then, man. I mean,
the eastern bloc women, they made world
records. That was when he was a, uh,
that was when he was a cruiserweight
look how thin he was. Yeah.
But you can't call them women if they
have the most [inaudible] penises,
fake beards and fat dicks.
They were, they were,
they set records that still to
this day haven't been broken. Wow.
And because they really were not women.
I mean,
there were women with massive amounts
of male hormones in their body. Flo Jo.
Yeah. She's, she's, uh,
thinks still sets the record right
now for what, whatever it was.
And she was also someone that was accused
of doing things. Yeah. I mean look,
track and field according to victor
contact, um, who uh, was the balco guy,
I had him on my podcast.
He was the guy that got um,
the clear to Barry bonds and all
those guys will undetected supposedly
undetectable steroids. He said track
and field is just a dirty sport,
just like Tour de France,
like just like cycling.
He's like disappointed them dirty sport.
You've got cars Louis trying to
call out Hussein bolt now. Right?
What are you showing us,
Janice at the top 100 meter times.
All the names crossed out.
Oh Wow. Steroids. Wow.
God Damn.
Well that's like when a Lance Armstrong
won the Tour de France and they took his
title away.
If you had to give that title to someone
who didn't test positive for anything,
you had to go back to 18th place.
Wow.
I was a dirty sport. You know, Bill
Burke said it best. He's like, he goes,
our psycho is better than your psycho.
They were all, you were all dirty.
There's a dirty sport. He was just better
at doing that sport while being dirty.
Yeah. If everybody's dirty,
then it's fair. Well, he won.
He won while everybody was
cheating. But I mean, did he have,
so is it still cheating if everybody's
doing it? It is and it isn't. I mean,
it is definitely cheating, but
everybody's cheating. Yes. Weird.
It's not good. See, you know, they
went off to the wrong thing. You know,
people were looking for drugs
to help them get stronger.
When it's not true food
that makes you stronger,
that's what you put into your system.
So you know, I know what you make them.
Food is great. You know,
yams, plantains, everything.
Beef bully beef, you know what's
better than that? That's that steroids.
Steroids are way better.
They work instantly better
if you just stay on them.
Like guys like Lance Armstrong,
they proved it.
You almost can't do toward the fronts
the way they were doing it without some
sort of chemical help. Like I've
heard it argued by physiologists.
They say it's actually better for your
body to be on steroids while you're doing
something like the Tour de France because
you give your body a chance to recover
because they're doing so much work over
the course of this race that without
having some sort of chemical enhancement
of your ability to recover, you do.
You just not going to be able to do it.
Help out your body, can't do it right.
The town.